we haven't checked in on our boy frankie
b flat in a while
there's a couple little videos they're
short they're short videos
uh here's the first one of course hello
again are my brothers and sisters
on our flat domed stationary earth
hope boys well with everybody i wanted
to say hello
well i haven't done a video in a while
but i'm out here in uh buckeye arizona
it's like 2 30 yeah that's why you think
the earth is flat you live in arizona
frankie
you should go out a little bit see the
world it's actually not flat well he's
from new york originally if you couldn't
tell
i am about maybe
300 miles from california
and i just wanted to show you
the sky here it's beautiful
it's gorgeous it's overcast
it's completely covered in clouds
now i'm 300 miles away
and those fires in california
wait a minute royce is he
yes is frankie implying that that's all
smoke
yes from california and it's what i
guess it's clogging up in the dome in
the dome yeah
say over 20 million
acres have been burnt that can't be
right
20 million eggs that can't be right
sounds like a lot that cannot be right
somebody please verify that cannot be
correct
it's been like this for days like a haze
over it
everybody's sick and they're telling me
yeah well people sleep because of the
virus and said ah it's not the virus is
this
it's this smoke that we're breathing in
okay you know the virus is not killing
us
it's the elite burning our earth
a flat earth flat earth and all i kept
thinking about
is those georgia guide stones
well anyway take care god bless you all
like i always say
well things must pass until our lord
appears
yeah look at this okay i had to look
this up because it was bothering me
um so california
sorry does consist of uh over a hundred
million acres
but that would be one-fifth of
california yeah completely burnt to a
crow i
i just don't see it being 20 million
acres buddy
um it's just over 100 million acres
so so what introduces to frankie b flat
was this uh
his love of fat cat food well and hormel
chili one more chili
this is um which is pretty much the same
thing
uh it was he was bothering this but
remember the very first video we played
he was bothering this grocery store
employee named chris this black kid
well he's just from a couple days ago
he's gone and revisited him now the
title this chris now believes in
that's that's the title i didn't forget
the last one so i'm gonna guess chris
wanted you to leave him alone
well let's see let's see if chris is
flat woke
hello again all my brothers and sisters
on our flight dome
station every year here's chris again
maybe we did a video a couple of months
back i was telling you about the planet
poor christmas i wanna i really want to
buy chris lunch
because i feel bad for him that was like
when i first started here
right and you thought i was crazy and
everything right
i was wondering what was going on well
what do you think now
now you might have been on something say
it looks like you hear it
you might have been on something we'll
see where it goes though
oh you started realizing the nice way of
saying
i just don't want to talk about it leave
me alone sure maybe you're on to
something with that
doing everything right
just research it man i told you yeah
well anyway
uh i will keep i know you're working the
thing i hate about frankie
is that he bothers people at their jobs
it is you see this a lot not just with
flat earthers but even with like people
who don't have any social graces
they'll go to the same bar or they'll go
to the same restaurant they've seen
you know whatever grocery store and
they'll keep talking to the employees
all the time
because employees are required to be
nice to you
and people kind of use that it's it's
to me it's [ __ ] up it's a [ __ ] up
thing to go to somebody at their job
where they're required to be nice to you
and go huh
the earth's flat am i right well you're
like look i just have to put this shitty
two dollar cans of chili up on the shelf
i might i hate this job i hate this job
i don't like coming here my day already
sucks
and you're bothering me and that's what
i don't like i like frankie he seems
like a harmless enough guy
i just hate people that bother people at
their jobs because this kid chris
he can't say leave me the [ __ ] alone of
course not
boys is watching us up there but thank
you chris and people were asking about
uh
what about that that black kid that
would give you that dirty look like he
didn't want to be bothered with you
thought it was crazy
and they said you know that little
[ __ ] bleep
they were sick by the way i wasn't
saying it but like the youtube comments
they were the one thing
one guy would would write an n
and then it was weird like i'd see
underneath another guy would write an
eye
and then two other guys were wrong
and he had to sit there listening oh i
haven't seen him i said when i
when i see him again i'll put him on
i'll put him on film
and uh you just you know said hello to
me now and i was like
well i'm glad all right let you go man
all right man
all right
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] guy's here again hey
frank is here by the way guys just just
look like you're busy he's going to
bother you
i love that man that thing where he goes
into the back
and then starts you know pretending to
do something yep
so he's yelled at everybody up one at a
time
makes my day and
i can't wait for it then you know what
else they were saying chris they were
saying things like
how do you let you know why would you
let those people handle your food
you know and then i was saying like
that's not right
that's not right but they i wasn't
saying that they were saying it chris
[Laughter]
when we see our lord in the clouds
and every knee shall bow and the grocery
store music playing over this is the
best part of my opinion
hey chris i'm doing a live stream i got
all the listeners asking me
could you say the 14 words you know what
those are
i'm not really sure what they are
oh oops i want to send frankie be flat
out live with with
[ __ ] stream labs on can you imagine
oh my god he would you would get him
killed mike please don't do that
please please please don't do that